et nous sommes justement avec antoine
veil l'avocat de julian assange bonsoir
en toi devez merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors tous les
regards sont désormais tournés vers la
justice britannique c'est une décision
extrêmement délicate à prendre pour le
juge avant justement d'en parler
première question comment va julian
assange
c'est la question qui revient en boucle
parce que tout le monde prend la mesure
du fait que n'ayant reçu absolument
aucune visite depuis le mois de mars ni
ses proches ni ses avocats ayant été
dans un état que le rapporteur des
nations unies a été écrit comme de la
torture psychologique et qui caractérise
un état on va dire de santé absolument
affreux atroce tant psychologiquement
que physiquement il est très diminué
on sait déjà que il est dans un état de
santé qui ne lui permet pas de se
défendre utilement ni pour le moment en
grande bretagne et nuit dans
l'éventualité d'un procès aux états unis
donc son état de santé véritablement au
coeur des débats
et on peut s'étonner que la communauté
internationale et l'angleterre en
premier lieu n'en prennent pas acte pour
ordonner rapidement des mesures qui
permettent de sauvegarder la santé de
d'assange
alors on lisait une décision extrêmement
délicate à prendre pour le juge qui va
est évidemment très observés selon vous
est-ce que ce juge ait les moyens
aujourd'hui de travailler en toute
indépendance et en toute sérénité est ce
que la justice est clairement sont sous
pression selon l'avocat vous êtes l
avocat que je suis il est comme tous les
gens qui soutiennent à 100 g il espère
que les critères de droit vont prospérer
vont permettre de faire barrière à la
demande des états unis
les critères de droit c'est d'abord de
démontrer qu'il s'agit d'un procès
politique
et la deuxième chose c'est de dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'état de santé d'assange
et les charges qu'il a depuis des années
par les états unis ne permet pas
l'extradition
maintenant ce qui nous fait douter et ce
qui nous fait craindre c
une succession de signaux très négatif
la première c'est comme je voulais dit
qu'il n'a plus accès à des avocats
depuis le mois de mars la seconde est le
père de julian assange l'évoqué à
l'instant c'est qu'il ya à peu près dix
jours on a découvert un nouvel acte
d'accusation dans une affaire qui date
depuis 2010 ça veut dire que les charges
si vous voulez sont assez peu établi
pour que dix jours avant l'ouverture
d'un procès sur des faits de dix à dix
ans on découvre des nouveaux éléments
assange n'a jamais pu prendre
connaissance de l'intégralité de son
dossier
donc si vous voulez des éléments comme
ça il y en a énormément qui nous font
dire que oui on a peut-être une justice
qui est un peu sous pression et un
pouvoir politique britannique qui comme
tous les autres pouvoirs du monde en
fait à peut-être du mal à s'opposer aux
états unis et à un processus qui nous ne
nous paraît plus du tout juridique mais
est devenu il ya déjà bien longtemps
éminemment politique aujourd'hui vous
craignez clairement que la raison d'état
se substitue aux droits en l'espèce déjà
il ya un précédent qui nous choque qui
est le précédent de chelsea manning donc
dans le cas de chelsea manning je vous
rappelle celle à la personne qui a été
inculpée et condamnée pour avoir
divulgué les informations
confidentielles dont assange aurait
permis si on en croit l'acte
d'accusation américain le piratage
même si on comprend pas et on n'est
jamais vraiment compris quels éléments
matériels justifierait c'est ce piratage
mais il est clair que depuis le début de
cette affaire
on a passé si vous voulez le statut
juridique et que les pressions qu'il
subit les surveillances qu'il subit
l'internement qu'il subit l'isolément
qu'il subit sont un traitement tout à
fait exceptionnel qui pour être clair
n'appartient pas à la sphère judiciaire
classique donc nous espérons
véritablement et c'est là on à dire la
dernière chance s'il est extradé après
sur le sol américain
plus personne d'autre que les américains
ne pourront faire quelque chose donc on
espère certainement un sursaut populaire
mais aussi surtout un sursaut de la
justice justement vous espère un sursaut
populaire né vous condamner le peu de
résonance aux collectives dans cette
affaire dans le monde francophone
notamment pourquoi selon vous ce peu de
de résonance ça fait aussi partie de la
stratégie qui a été conduite contre
assange à savoir qu'on a indûment
complexifier son dossier en le faisant
passer pour tout un tas de choses qu'il
n'est pas aujourd'hui comme l'a rappelé
son père assange et doit être considérée
comme un éditeur de presse
c'est pas lui qui donne les informations
il fait que les publier et à ce titre là
il doit bénéficier d'une protection très
particulière mais pourquoi pas de
mobilisation déjà parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas que ce n'est peut-être
pas un dossier qui intéresse seulement
les états unis je rappelle que c'est
assange qui a permis notamment de mettre
la lumière sur le fait que les
présidents français étaient espionnés
par les services secrets américains
donc c'est un dossier qu'il ya des
ramifications dans le monde francophone
mais par la complexité des faits par des
campagnes négatives qui ont été
conduites contre assange
et puis par une indifférence générale
parce qu'il ya peut-être un déficit
d'information il est vrai qu'on a dans
le monde francophone à mon avis une
attention qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux de ce procès lorsqu il faudrait
aussi le sauver c'est d'ailleurs l'un
des coeurs des du débat julien assange
mène des activités journalistiques ou
non c'est à cette question qu'il faudra
répondre puisqu'il devrait être protégé
non dans ce cas de figure les médias
aussi n'aurait pas dans ce cas précis
jouit non forme de de solidarité avec
lui il a un rapport de toute façon très
ambiguë avec beaucoup de choses les
médias en sont une l'opinion publique en
est une autre
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
voulu se laisser enfermer dans une boîte
qui est assez provocateur sur certains
aspects qui a manqué de soutien
institutionnel mais je tiens à rappeler
quand même que les informations de
wikileaks était publié conjointement
avec tous les plus grands médias
internationaux français allemand anglais
espagnol est ce qu'il ya un seul
journaliste de ces médias qui a été
accusé et est-ce qu'il ya un seul
journaliste qui aurait fait ce qu'on
reproche à assange qui serait espionner
isolé traité comme le dernier des
terroristes j'ai dit souvent qu avant
même d'avoir été jugé il a été dépouillé
de tous ses droits
même les plus
les montèrent droit de voir ses proches
et c'est donc c'est vrai qu'on était un
petit peu étonné de ne pas avoir un
sursaut du monde journalistique pour le
protéger parce que si lui est extradé et
condamné alors le simple fait de
diffuser des informations dont personne
ne conteste qu'elles sont vraies et
d'intérêt public deviendra dangereux et
que les droits démocratiques ne pourront
plus être normalement exercée si
l'information est finalement filtré par
le pouvoir en place quel que soit la
décision l'une et l'autre pari parti
pourra faire appel ça veut dire que
julian assange risque fort de rester là
où il est ça risque de prendre encore
beaucoup de temps vous le craignez non
parce que le système britannique fait
que l'appel n'est pas un appel comme
nous nous l'entendons dans le système
français notamment
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut pas
imaginer que l'audience qui va se
dérouler au puy se déroule en ce moment
est une audience on va dire deux choses
en réalité c'est l'audience principal
qui risquent de déterminer son sort et
le juge d'appel vérifiera évidemment la
régularité de certaines choses mais il
ne sera pas un juge de 2e ressort comme
nous nous en avons l'habitude
donc il faut véritablement que chacun
prenne la mesure de ce qui se passe et
que effectivement la justice soit pas
sous pression
l'enjeu est d'avoir une justice libre
mais soit observée et que l'on puisse
dire si la décision de l'extrader prise
que c'est une décision qui de toute
façon est une décision qui viole les
droits fondamentaux d'assange est donc à
partir du moment où il sera extradé on
est déjà dans un processus qui est un
processus qui n'est plus juridique et je
pense que face à ça il faut que les
démocraties notamment européennes
puissent tenir tête aux états unis et
demander que s'il doit être jugé le soit
dans un cadre différent avec des
garanties beaucoup beaucoup plus forte
merci beaucoup antoine veil avocat de
julien assange un de nous avoir accordé
cet entretien en direct sur rt france
merci m